[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
for years vladimir putin has been
nurturing the idea of a russia that is
once again great and powerful in today's
russia things like prosperity standards
of living and welfare are secondary what
matters what really matters is the image
of power we've seen this illustrated
through the terrible fury putin has
unleashed in ukraine a place where he
had nothing to gain except the narrative
so how does putin manage to inject this
sentiment into russian society what is
the kremlin doing to boost patriotism
and to what extent is the army being
used for this purpose today on
visualpolitik we are going to answer
these questions but first let's take a
look at a bit of history have you heard
about russia's young army cadets
national movement well listen up
[Music]
yun armia the young army
[Music]
the years directly following the fall of
the soviet union were very complicated
for russia the country fell into
absolute ribbon inflation sword the
ruble lost most of its value and the
crown jewels of the economic fabric were
appropriated by oligarchs we are talking
about difficulties that also extended to
the army
[Music]
the shortfalls of the russian armed
forces were exposed after their
intervention in georgia in 2008. that
was a real turning point this is
something that we covered in a recent
video about russia's strengths i'll
leave you the link in the description
after this war putin launched a profound
military reform a reform for which the
russian president received significant
assistance
the price of oil was breaking all
historic records and thus filling the
kremlin's usual amiga coffers there was
no longer any needs to skimp so russian
military spending roughly doubled
between the years 2005 and 2018.
although there are no officially
confirmed figures experts point out that
russian military spending actual
spending exceeds 50 billion annually
that's approximately 4 of russian gdp
[Music]
over the last decade russia has made a
major investment effort into new
equipment for example during this time
more than 600 new aircraft 840
helicopters and 2 300 drones were added
to the armed forces the kremlin has
revamped 70 of its fighter planes and 27
of its armored vehicles russia's
military industry has also developed new
technological capabilities along these
lines russia's electronic warfare tools
which could be used to intercept or
block enemy communications and drones
and are considered to be able to give
those of the united states a run for
their money
but hold on a minute because the putin
government still has a few million left
over to do other kinds of things for
example from 2021 a four year 185
million dollar program is underway with
a single goal to increase the patriotic
education of russians yes yes that's
correct among other things these plans
include getting at least six hundred
thousand children to join the ranks of
the yunamiya the russian young army
cadets
[Music]
they can join from the age of eight
until they reach the age of majority
yunamiya is certainly a worthy heir to
the young pioneers of the soviet era you
see the vladimir lenin all union pioneer
organization was the youth organization
used by the soviet union to promote the
ideological principles of communism it
existed between 1922 and 1990 and
brought together boys and girls between
the ages of 10 and 15.
membership peaked at 25 million members
in the 1970s the organization had the
so-called young pioneer palaces they
served as meeting centers where the
young people participated in games
manual labor and some sports activities
then during summer vacations these young
people went to the young pioneer camps
they were like the scouts and the girl
guides but with communist insignia on
their backpacks but it went much further
than games and camps at the age of 15
the pioneers could join consomol another
youth organization that served as a
gateway to the communist party of course
compared to the soviet era putin's
yunamiya has no links to communism but
has become an organization focused
primarily on the military it places
special emphasis on patriotism and
service to the armed forces with a
training program led by reserve officers
what's more the unimer even has its own
uniform
the uniform of the yunamiya is a classic
khaki coloured military outfit with a
very characteristic element on the head
its members wear red berets with an
insignia bearing the yunamiya logo
nothing less than the red star of the
russian army superimposed on the head of
an eagle among the activities undertaken
by this youth organization are rival
practice first aid training and martial
arts fighting
once a year the russian ministry of
defence organizes the yunamiya congress
and that is where you can find
everything nationalist rallies weapons
on display everywhere sports
competitions among members and even a
science fair to attract the brainiest of
the brainiacs and very important in
order to set the mood a dj plays new
versions of the old patriotic tunes with
the addition of hip hop effects
all with one goal to show young russians
that nothing is cooler than the young
army cadets they have it well thought
out surely all of this is more
attractive than just drumming into them
the solemn oath of the yunamiya warning
what follows is a reduced version of
this oath lest the full version induce
in some of you an unusual russian
patriotism check it out i swear to
strive for victories and studies and
sports to be a patriot and a worthy
citizen of russia except for the oath of
the young army but hold on a minute
because this is not the only strategy
the russian government is using to
promote patriotic military education
amongst the young it also finances
private entities that organize contests
with disciplines as varied as knowledge
of russian history and others more
useful in a future war scenario such as
map reading or shooting tests with
weapons but if there is one thing the
kremlin has really gone all out on it
has been to build something that looks
capable of promoting patriotism for the
whole family something that will thrill
children and adults alike we are talking
about nothing short of an entire theme
park and guess what pack your bags
because we're going on a trip
[Music]
patriot park russia's disneyland
[Music]
european children dream of going to
disneyland paris north american ones
dream of going to disney world in
orlando well putin has made it his
mission to make everyone in russia want
to go to patriot park and yes sure it
would be nice to have roller coasters in
the park but let's say that the
kremlin's intentions go in another
direction we are talking about a
military theme park dedicated to the
russian army located in the town of
kobinka an hour's drive from moscow and
the russian ministry of defence has
spared no expense
it has set aside about 250 million euros
that's 280 million us dollars for
construction and everything has been
taken care of down to the smallest
detail for example they say that the
food consists of army rations and of
course you have to wonder if such a
level of realism is really needed but be
that as it may the park is designed for
the enjoyment of the whole family
although once again as usually happens
with these types of facilities the idea
is to particularly impress the youngest
ones but in the best style of putin's
russia in this park young people can
participate in activities that are
completely different from what we are
used to seeing in amusement parks for
example despite the incredible graphics
kids are probably sick of playing war in
video games so being able to touch a
real gun and even fire a shot or two is
a real draw card nor should other
activities such as virtually driving a
tank using a 3d printer or participating
in the training of trained dogs be
underestimated
in addition at patriot park visitors can
get up close to a lot of tanks armoured
transport vehicles and missile launching
systems from all eras you could say it's
a complete tour through russia's war
history and take note because patriot
park is also the place for business year
after year the park hosts a new edition
of the army forum this is an
international event where russia
exhibits its latest military tours
[Music]
of course without going into detail
there are always the foreign delegations
sent by putin's friends after all the
main buyers of russian arms are well
known india vietnam china and bangladesh
in asia iran and iraq in the middle east
algeria and egypt in africa nicaragua
and venezuela in the americas in any
case it is clear that this type of forum
is always a good place to do business
russia uses defense show to try and
boost arms sales to middle east you want
an example then look at this saudi
arabia and the united arab emirates are
very interested in russian weapons let's
just say they have had some problems
with buying them from other countries
because of the war in yemen so they
dropped by to see what they could pick
up well that's another story because the
real purpose of this installation is to
make the russians see the full might of
their country's armed forces
[Music]
the victory in world war ii which they
know as the great patriotic war is by
far the main argument used to appeal to
the emotions of visitors years ago they
even organized a large reenactment of
the storming of the reichstag in
addition in the theme park there is also
an interactive museum called the 1418
steps to victory this is precisely the
number of days that elapsed from the
moment hitler declared war on the soviet
union until the moment germany
surrendered and yes i know what many of
you are thinking but josh so many towns
have quirky museums what's the
fascination with this one well basically
because i have not told you yet about
the most remarkable thing about patriot
park it's something that tells us a lot
about what russia is like nowadays i'm
referring to nothing less than the main
cathedral of the russian armed forces
[Music]
this cathedral was consecrated in 2020
to commemorate the 75th anniversary of
the soviet victory over nazi germany its
exterior is like any other orthodox
cathedral except for its khaki green
color more interesting is its interior
in the stained glass windows religious
images give way to soviet war medallions
and the diameter of its main dome is
19.45 metres a figure chosen expressly
to symbolize the year of victory
[Music]
but visualpolitik fans there are two
details of this cathedral that are truly
fascinating the first is the floor and
that's not exactly because it's made of
marble from the euros because that's not
the case the point is that someone in
the kremlin came up with the idea of
melting down weapons and tanks seized
from nazi germany to make the floor of a
temple the goal is that if one day you
ever visit the main cathedral of the
russian armed forces every step you take
will have you trampling on the vile
fascist enemy the other most remarkable
element of this cathedral are its
mosaics it is possibly one of the
orthodox temples that brings together
the most mosaics in the whole world but
what makes them unique is their theme
next to the religious images there are
other mosaics that justify events in
recent russian history how recent well
it turns out not as recent as they had
planned
russia ditches putin mosaic in army
church the design they were already
working on can be seen on the screen but
it seems that in the end they found it a
bit too much to elevate putin to the
altars at least as long as he is still
the president of the country
of course the rest of the mosaics are
not to be missed either they are
dedicated to the soviet and russian
armies there is a very significant one
in which two angels look down on a group
of soldiers with their modern weapons a
list commemorates a long series of
conflicts soviet interventions to crush
the revolution in hungary the prague
spring and the invasion of afghanistan
also added are the two russian wars in
chechnya and other more recent missions
that russian propaganda calls restoring
peace in georgia the return of crimea
and the fight against international
terrorism in syria and you know what in
other matters not so much but here the
russians are forward thinking they have
left room for adding more conflicts in
the future yes that's right ukraine will
soon join this kind of national reminder
of course we are missing perhaps the
most important feature of all listen up
the besieged fortress
russia knows that it is no longer the
soviet union of the cold war era that it
is no longer one of the two dominant
superpowers on the planet but putin
refuses to play a secondary role and we
have seen it indeed we have witnessed it
in ukraine where for months putin had
the country surrounded by land sea and
air until he finally attacked also that
russia would continue to be seen as a
great superpower
and keep in mind that russia no longer
means only russia but also of the other
countries that formed the soviet zone of
influence in this way the russian
government is sending a very clear
message let everyone know that russian
interests do not end where russia's
borders end something similar was
advocated in late january by vladimir
vasilev parliamentary leader of united
russia putin's party when he asked the
kremlin for support for pro-russian
separatists in the donbass look at this
and take note because here we have one
of the big key aspects of the kremlin's
marketing the russian government has
been preparing its citizens for conflict
for years to this end it presents russia
as a fortress under siege their aim is
to make russians believe that they are
surrounded by enemies and therefore have
to be prepared to defend the homeland
they often even draw parallels with the
attack on the soviet union in the second
world war and naturally from the comfort
of our sofas in our homes we can think
how exaggerated is this putin but the
truth is that this message does resonate
in russian society it really does in a
recent survey conducted by the levada
center for sociological research look at
what the second concern of russian
citizens is
more than half of russians are really
panicking about the possibility of a
world war not a war in ukraine but a
full-scale world war it is evident that
the russian propaganda around the
besieged fortress story is having an
effect and that's why headlines like
this one are always music to the
kremlin's ears
nato countries urge to supply more
weapons to ukraine
the pretext putin needs to do as he
pleases is that of security and alleged
threats because come on obviously most
ordinary russians don't want a war
rations are like you and me they want to
work they want prosperity they want
freedom
[Music]
but naturally that patriotism that has
been instilled by the kremlin for
decades makes russians feel obliged to
defend their russian brothers in the
donbass
the successful annexation of crimea in
2014 boosted russian patriotism and at
the same time it was useful for putin to
conceal from his own people that the
russian economy was no longer growing at
the same pace as it was at the beginning
of the century so given what we have
seen it should come as no surprise that
the kremlin is trying to repeat the move
with a russia hit by pandemics inflation
and corruption allegations in other
words we cannot rule out that the whole
conflict is a genuine diversionary
maneuver
certainly there was not many other
reasons but having come to this point
it's your turn what's your take on the
attack on ukraine leave us your comments
below and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe to the channel
while you're there all the best i'll see
you next time
[Music]